[Music]
the protests have a time been violent
but it didn't deter
hundreds from turning out for a sixth
week
on wednesday rallies were sparsely
attended yet clashes started early
as a group of indigenous misak tried to
topple a statue of christopher columbus
they were stopped by riot police with
tear gas and sun grenades
dozens were injured
we are performing an ancestral
revitalization of the historical memory
of the indigenous
populations of colombia in the midst of
the 21st century there should be no
space for racist representations of
colonial power
that marginalizes and excludes our
communities
human rights watch says it has
documented at least
20 killings as well as illegal beatings
sexual assaults and arbitrary detentions
it accuses the colombian police of
egregious abuses
and is calling on the government to take
urgent measures to protect people's
right
and commit to police reform
we are dealing with a police force that
lacks basic standards of training and
accountability
and that above all doesn't have the
sufficient oversight to act in a manner
that ensures the basic respect of human
rights
president ivan duke says he will propose
changes to policing that include putting
body cameras on officers
and creating a new human rights
directorate
the protesters are demanding a
demilitarization of the police force
and that officers crimes are placed
under the jurisdiction of civilian
courts
international pressure to do so is
growing
demonstrators have also been staging a
protest in front of the hotel tecandama
where the leaders of the protests have
been meeting with the delegation of the
inter-american commission on human
rights
tasked on investigating the abuses
committed during the protests
the government is not listening and
watchdog institutions in the country are
controlled by the government
criminal complaints fall on deaf ears
that's why we need international
organizations to help us
to achieve the safety guarantees we
cannot get internally
members of the commission have also
spoken to government officials
judges and civil society organizations
during a three-day visit
they are expected to release
recommendations next week
in the meantime negotiations between
protesters and the government
remained stalled leaving the crisis on
the streets
with no end in sight alice al-jazeera
bogota